[Music]
technology is so powerful and has done
so much to transform our world but have
we become any happier consciousness
hacking to me is all about creating
tools and technologies that help
humanity evolve an exploration of how
technology can be in service of
spiritual development and humanity
scientific Berner psychedelic
experimental open and curious community
a bunch of curious individuals who are
open to exploring their minds and
exploring how it can build technology
that supports growth
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about
consciousness hacking and so much more
we have Joshua field joining us on the
show hello hello thank you so much for
coming on brother good to see my very
very excited for this we just finished
up doing a bunch of partnership
interviews with your awakened future
summit which those are slowly trickling
in but Clea online now really excited to
be releasing those that was such a good
summit because it don't know Josh fields
is the executive director of
consciousness happy which is a global
community working on cutting-edge tools
for transforming human consciousness you
can find the links in the by below -
Kohaku if-- as well as neo gnosis calm
and the Facebook and YouTube pages for
consciousness hacking Joshua let's start
things off with one of our favorite
questions to ask our guests what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world cool
big big start man oh so we live in an
age of paradox I don't know if you saw
Jamie we was talk at the awaken future
summit he basically says those three
things going on we have this exponential
curve of progress going up an
exponential curve of claps going down
and so basically things have never been
better they've never been worse and if
you can have like take on the
transcendence Buddhists everything is
perfect the way it is that is also true
so I've actually grappled with this
quite a lot like where are we going and
like as this technological revolution
actually aiding us and I think the
answer is yes and yet so we've we've
almost eradicated poverty life
expectancies doubled over the last
hundred or so years and yet
simultaneously existential risks never
been greater we are depleting the very
ecosystem by which we can actually make
this progress and I've been torn mine I
finished a master's at CI yes that is my
dissertation thesis on civilization
claps and claps dynamics and it's a real
tough one to Tulsa worth because we have
this exponential complexity curve
in the past the more and more I mean if
civilization collapse literature is
anything to go by the more complex the
society tends to become the lot higher
the likelihood it is to actually
systemic failures mmm so we have
beautiful progress exponential
complexity existential risks and really
which way it goes is where it remains to
be seen what are the things that we need
to embody the most to make sure that it
goes on the positive trajectory
so I think the issues us we're gonna use
this exponential complexity curve as an
example so there was an American
anthropologist Joseph Tainter donor she
read his work the collapse of complex
societies and basically it says as
societies become more and more complex
they add layers and layers of
bureaucracy in order to make better
sense of their problems now what we have
now is this technological complexity
going through the roof we have
ecological complexity we have socio
economic complexity and yet our capacity
to actually handle said complexity call
that cognition call it wisdom call it
consciousness is actually more of a flat
gradient and my sense is that the more
and more these curves decouple the
higher the likelihood that we're gonna
actually end up collapsing and so for me
the most important thing to actually try
to do in order to transcend these risks
is to somehow collapse the curve it
sorts to that to hack the curve because
we ain't gonna stop the complexity curve
yes but we can actually hack the
consciousness curve and that's
essentially the essence of my work
mmm-hmm yeah okay so the idea is that if
we can get our own wisdom the wisdom
race if we can get the wisdom to align
as quickly as possible with exponential
increases in technology and complexity
they're happening we have a greater
chance of not collapsing the
civilization that's my sense that's my
sense and there's so many other like
potential clap claps factors but really
complexity is a huge one and but the
other distinction that I made there was
is like the tint er didn't actually
speak to is this difference between
complication and complexity haveta
Nassim Taleb and what we have now is a
globalized economic system okay that is
actually highly complicated as well as
complex well the economic side is highly
complicated okay and a complicated
system is highly fragile and you see
that in 2008 right one Domino when the
banking system fails and there's a
contagion effect in the whole system
it's fragile a truly complex system is
actually anti fragile there's an acute
stressor to the system and that system
actually ends up enhancing and
amplifying its fortitude yes through
said stressor so I think tinder could
have reframed complexity as complication
so we have high
have a complicated system and highly
highly complex technology in ecology to
add to that system so we have to hack
this consciousness in order to make make
better sense of that and there are
various other risk factors involved and
one that I'd like to talk about a lot is
information people haven't quite
understood the the severity of what it
means to scale map misinformation and
disinformation that fake news is
actually an existential problem because
as sense-making organisms think about it
just biological terms if you can
actually trust the information that's
coming into your environment you're an
organism destined for failure and I know
it's in the UK there's some stuff just
now in The Times wrote an article but
Jeremy Corbyn the leader of the Labour
Party saying he has health problems like
and he's not fit to govern and he's just
come out and flatly said this is all
actually made up and Here I am sitting
and reading these things and because of
the amount of Lies that's in the media
of cause of the corruption of
information in our systems I can
actually trust the information that's
coming in and so the very fact that
we're getting more complex more
complicated juxtaposed with an inability
to make sense of that stuff and then you
throw in like a cognitive overload where
we can't actually make sense of anything
because for so overwhelmed this is a
really really problematic situation and
yet I'm hopeful that crisis precedes
transformation and they were actually on
the precipice of some sort of generous
Daniels Martin Berger says phase shift
my old professor brian swims says a
degree a great leap of being akin to
that of atoms and molecules single sales
and multi-celled organism the problem is
we don't know which way that's going to
go we could collapse up or we could
collapse down
and I think a lot is going to be
determined and how we actually use
wisdom in order to navigate through some
of these issues
Wow yeah that was a very good synthesis
Wow yeah let me say one more piece to
them this is where wisdom comes in so
the biological lens unlike information
systems collapsing it makes a lot of
sense from a rational perspective right
if you can't trust the information
that's circulating in a system it's a
reduction in information coherency this
is problematic for sense making yeah
from a more and I think this is again if
we if we bring wisdom into this what if
the sage has been trying to say what are
some of the virtues of the sages one of
the virtues is truth and there's a there
was a British historian called Sir John
glob who showed that each civilization
studied about 20 civilizations and
showed that each civilization goes
through seven stages there's the age of
triumph or honor where honor integrity
and truth are really important values
the gladiators come in they take over
the city and it ends in the age of
decadence this is written in 1972 he
said in the age of decadence there's a
loss of truth from public discourse
narcissism and materialism take on the
values value structures du jour and
celebrities gain the positions of power
does this sound familiar
I think we have to the embedding wisdom
is actually an existential necessity if
civilization collapse history is
anything to go by we have to actually
start reintroducing some of these values
that made us effective civilizations in
the first place and I think a lot of its
to do with how truth translates into
information coherency that's a central
pillar is being able to disseminate
truth to each other for overall
inclusive global fitness how do you make
sense of problems if you know that in
game theory terms all the other you
don't you can't trust information from
other other players in the game yeah
yeah that information coherency is one
of the most important we have pillars
that needs to be corrected and so how do
we incentivize people to speak in truth
instead of in manipulation and
misinformation to try and like self deal
my sense is a lot of this comes down to
the meta-narrative of the day right
we've internalized social Darwinism we
assume us to be competitive
bloodthirsty organisms all out to win or
light to win each other over right so
we've got these like when Lewis dynamics
embedded in our capitalist system we
assume the worst we assume people are
going to deceive and my sense is that is
until large extent true that we have to
actually guard against the fact that
there is always going to be an incentive
to cheat with regards to truth so for
example if nine countries getting rid of
nuclear bombs and North Korea says hey
I'm getting rid of mine too and they
cheat then you know they went on a game
theory terms they end up winning they
consolidate the power changing the story
of who and what we are coupled with
incentive systems to actually
disincentivize deceit and incentivize
more clear information dissemination
yeah there's really the drug submission
that's needed and I think from a
meta-narrative
yes we're competitive in selfish beings
and but evolution in biology shows that
were also highly highly collaborative
this big but big by a lady called Sarah
Coakley is a professor at Cambridge and
speaks that cooperation actually goes
down to like singular cell organisms
that single cell organisms will actually
commit suicide in order for the greater
evolution of the whole the altruism is
embedded at the bottom yeah so let's not
be naive to think this can just be done
but we need to upgrade our stories
throughout and systems to incentivize
those type of it this and reflect this
type of behavior yeah so okay so we need
a grand metod narrative that gets us to
better understand our origins and who we
are and then we need it the right
information coherency systems that help
us put together the right incentives for
for truth and for collaboration as well
as continue some competitive competition
along the way an idea of creation and
stuff raising the baseline of living the
degrees of freedom for everyone
sure
and yeah yeah yeah in the wisdom race to
be able to handle the increases in
consciousness at the same time as where
the exponential technology so
geopolitics are getting more and more
complex can the wisdom catch up yeah
then things like consciousness is
hacking help us with the wisdom catching
up so okay let's let's do some of the
some of the journey so you're born in
Scotland and then you raise her until
you're about 18 what was that like skull
is a special we country five million
people with a very real down-to-earth
ethic it's still kind of in a bit of a
post-industrial cultural age and I think
part of my desire to get away from
Scotland was that can actually be quite
a binding that any attempts to think
outside the box are and it often through
through through fun but it but often
ridiculed it's like don't outshine like
just you know don't don't don't think to
outside the box so the real culture
there and that culture is also very
beautiful you can make to San Francisco
or in everyone's a visionary and
everyone's thinking outside the box and
sometimes you're like well where's the
grounding it's a very grounded place and
I love it man and and I think ultimately
I'll end up back there in the future but
for now I need to come and drink from
the reservoirs of the eat of the west
coast and think some of that stuff back
with me yeah yeah it's good okay and
then to went to Oxford for economics and
then in the investment baking London
what were those years like
Paulsen yeah yeah I mean the more the
University part in the banking part ya
know at a great education experience I
think what has been interesting is
having to remove myself from a very or
having graduated from a very credible
institution and then go on in this
contemplative journey seeing the the
some of the failures and the the fragile
spots of something that's credible and
you know has like an academic academic
stamp of approval so am i and in terms
of banking some of something similar I
used to use the term a conceptual Ponzi
scheme so like in an investment bank
everybody thinks the person knows no
above them knows what's going on in the
hierarchy until you get to the very top
and then the head thinks the person
below him or her knows what's going on
in the hierarchy and in the hierarchy so
there's this circle of actually knowing
nothing and I think that seems to be
there's a lot of bravado there's a lot
of ego and there's not a lot of I think
deep systemic thinking there's some of
these institutions which i think is
what's trying to emerge from a lot of
these public intellectuals that you've
been interviewing for example yeah but
overall Oxford incredible banking
beautiful friends not quite for me yeah
I think you nailed something there which
is so cool that when you have these
these organisms like investment banking
that may not have calibrated their
wisdom to be to catch up to the
craziness of the the the entropic
systems that are existing in our
civilization right now that if you can
do things like potentially help with
consciousness hacking things or
increasing the amount of information
coherency from public intellectuals into
their spheres that type of thing yeah
that can be a massive change for the
direction of like investment banking we
may not have financial crises these
types of things I think these are
crucial or like 10% of every single
venture capital fund could go to the
Department of nature maintenance right
or something like that those are really
interesting things that need
be discussed more and more enlightened
about when we get our intertwined
aspects that we have with the ecosystems
that sustain us then we say well maybe
part of our fund should go towards that
because we want to make sure children
have a planet type thing
then what about what was the the thing
that got you to go all right off to the
west coast of the United States so I
definitely had a bit of a quarter life
crisis of having extremely piqued
non-jew experiences through meditation
through lucid dreaming and feeling this
deep deep sense of healing as I started
engaging in these practices and seeing
that and banking like I had everything
at a good degree I had you know the
money the the status and yet I was still
like deeply and secure I'm just and I
saw myself claiming this hierarchy and I
realized that it was never gonna be
enough that I just knew that in 10 years
time there's always gonna be that one
more piece to climb before I'm gonna be
happy and then there I go on a
meditation a tree I'm a pastor for 10
days and I am so [ __ ] foo
yeah I don't need anything else yeah
yeah I'm healing my emotional
intelligence is deepening my
self-awareness is increasing I love it
so it got me thinking like well how do i
how do i give people access to these
states that's healing these these ways
of being because going in a tentative
pass or treatment it's it's a privilege
yeah yeah you know if you get two kids
and working three jobs I mean there's
often times that I hear some anger when
people are like what what do you mean
meditation retreat and I think it's it's
justified anger it's a real sense of
privilege that we can just step back but
you shouldn't the social fabric should
be structured that way where it's so
difficult right to go ten days to Orion
right it's so difficult
yeah we're slaves to the system and yet
given those parameters the work that I
went came over to San Francisco thinking
about was how do we scale personalize
and make universally accessible these
states
awakening and healing and that's
basically the essence of what I've been
working on for the last couple of years
okay so scaling states of increasing our
wisdom increasing our healing and
hacking into our consciousness what are
let's start maybe breaking down some of
the ways to do this on a you know on a
systemic meta perspective give us some
of the ideas of how we do this you
listen to the passion of meditation as
one of the ways there are so many other
ways to hack it yeah so traditionally
consciousness acting as an organization
has been focused in modern technology
and so for example one modern technology
that could help hack consciousness is
the Muse headband which is biofeedback
device that gives you audio feedback to
show you when your actual brain waves
are in meditative States and so you're
it's acting as a support system to guide
you more quickly into deeper levels of
awareness and the tech is a very very
early stage so you even have something
like headspace you know an app on your
phone Sam Harris is waking up then the
next layers of this are things like
ultrasonic neuromodulation or you've had
geo Sanguinetti on ultrasound to certain
parts of the brain which we think might
be associated with sale for a minute of
thinking but I think again I'm maybe
overdoing the curves today but conscious
is acting in the trans tech space
started maybe five years ago we're still
here in the exponential curve we've not
even had any yeah so that's the tech
side then there's obviously the
psychedelic side there's the breathwork
side mm-hmm but really what we're
focusing on is the cutting-edge ways of
transforming consciousness
not so much the things that been around
for thousands of years but really had to
be here's a better better way of putting
is how good can we get at transforming
human consciousness mmm given all the
tools to be a participative Ozel yeah
our conference awaken futures was about
this right it's like how do we bring
together the psychedelic community the
meditation community the tech community
the most potent potent transformative
communities and see what emerges from
those synergies you were there mm-hmm
definitely one of my favorite
conferences ever I loved it I loved it
and ok let's let's let's take these
let's go let's let's even take ourselves
back so there's a good amount of
indigenous elders that are telling us
that ok we can become awakened in a
natural spiritual way uh-huh and that
has been happening for millennia where
we've been doing things like
understanding that we all come from this
great mother this great God this great
all that is and we all come from that
and that paying our respect to to the
start to the planet to the ecosystems
that we live on the air the water the
food is one of the ways to become really
spiritual moment-to-moment naturally and
then we have now we have had a pretty
explosive entrance of the neuro
technologies that you are listing these
closed-loop feedback systems with bio
signal processing to show when I'm
actually in my meditative States versus
not psychedelic Renaissance so there's a
lot of new ways now that are that maybe
indigenous leaders wouldn't call
necessarily natural spiritual connection
but they're we're all men ting our
spiritual connection so where do you see
the augmentations of neuro tech and
psychedelics how do they play with what
the indigenous elders are saying it's a
natural spiritual connection
so there's this couple of ways I'd
answer this the first is there seems to
be a continuum of what you might call a
spiritual authenticity whereby the
meditation purists or the very start and
they're saying if it's not just using
your breath you're cheating yeah you're
using something outside of yourself
meditation purists yes okay okay and
then you move over to the psychedelic
purist okay and the meditation pure is
looking at psychedelic doers and saying
you guys are cheating and then the
psychedelic purist then looks to the
technology Augmented awakening field and
says you guys are cheating and so
there's this [ __ ] there's this continuum
of what people see as what is natural
what is the authentic spiritual
awakening and I think quite simply this
bifurcation between what we think to be
us and what we think to be the other is
actually inherently part of the problem
so for example nature and culture has
there been a more disastrous bifurcation
in concept mmm oh yeah
the bifurcation of technology of
artificial and natural of technology and
spirituality I would suggest is actually
just as harmful if not more harmful for
and I'm just not true
yeah for our worldview than nature and
culture and so I think what has been
happening is that technology has been
designed away from the natural rhythms
of life
yes it's linear it's not circular it's
not sustainable it's user abuse it threw
it away
it's consumerism unless we embed
technology in a more intelligent way of
evolution we're screwed
but that is not to say that we can't
that is actually to say that technology
is an expression of us in the same way a
rock as an expression of nature
technology is an expression of of us
what feels off I feel is we're designing
it in a way that is out of alignment
yeah yeah artificial and natural false
dichotomy
if artificial starts to be designed in
line with the natural yes yes okay how
does technology how does what is this as
like Kogi elders called this younger
brother that is doing all this creative
engineering and tinkering and and
building how does that essence how do
they gain this older brother wisdom of
connecting on a natural level to the
ecosystems that sustain us and embed
that in the technology to make it
actually spiritual soon there's not that
that false bifurcation that you're
speaking of yeah so if you think of
technology as a black box what is
important for our evolution and my sense
is the input on the output of that black
box the input is from what level of
consciousness are we building from we
are going to encode all of our biases
all of our [ __ ] all of our both
individual cultural biases all of our
blind mimetic dispositions into the code
of technology itself and so level one is
you transform the consciousness of the
individuals you transform the
consciousness of the organization's and
you make sure that the outfit from that
black box is in service of well-being
flourishing and basically in greater
service of life capital L okay it's not
technology that's ethical Tristan Harris
is a you know ethical tech extremely
important movement yes the technology at
the moment for human wellbeing is like
minus ten on a scale of -10 to +10 is
harming us internally neutral tech is
going to take it to zero or we're saying
is we actually have to build tools that
because technology is ubiquitous it's
universally disseminated
it actually has to synergize and better
our census of where we take it to +10
yeah that's super ideal I like that I
like that per spectrum maybe it's not
all the way negative ten maybe it's at
like negative eight right admit negative
10 is like you're like hey in the
lecture yeah okay so then let's say that
Oh
let's say that it's at minus five and
we're trying to move it to neutral Tech
and then even towards positive tech yeah
I think a really good example is I think
a lot of people have this example where
they're they're trying to go somewhere
like sporadically they're like oh I'm
trying to go from San Francisco to Los
Angeles and maybe add a you know like
the the day before is when you plan on
it
if tech was really really good if we
were really good with technology it
would be as simple as my intention would
go in into the input and then it would
be a big ping out to people that are
already transiting down there that I
know or that no mirror that our second
connection and then just for people to
simply say I accept this person's
profile and and then just like that the
connection happens but we are we're
still distant away from these these were
by several leaps also let's let's talk
about the people that are making the
technology that are inputting into the
black box because we talked about you
know meditation neuro technology
biotechnology psychedelics
what are the ways to help the engineers
the designers do we need ethicists and
philosophers there with them moral
scientists there with them as they
create the technologies do they need to
go through experiences that transcend
their own egos before they embark on
building these technologies with teams
or what do we do there I mean take the
ancient wisdom piece would an ancient or
indigenous tribe allow three-year-olds
to carry the most potentially violent or
a powerful tool of the tribe probably
not mm-hmm
if we get exponentially more powerful
and we don't mature and the people who
are building these tools aren't growing
at the same rate as this exponential
potency that's a problem so this is this
is an imperative that people's
consciousnesses actually catch up with
the level of a power that is actually
becoming decentralized this is going to
be universally accessible power
potentially one day since that day
biology for example
a lot of that is and so sorry to your
question about philosophers Wyatt why
for me philosophy is such a an
underrated endeavor is that we are
actually all encoded with these biases
that we have no idea exists so there's a
book by Richard tarnis the passion of
the Western mind and it's like we assume
that we think in a certain way and we
see the world in a certain way because
that's the way the world is right and
you can go all the way back to Kant to
show that that's just not the case you
know we see the world through our
neurological cultural and biological
filters on a cultural perspective the
West has celebrated rationality logic
abstraction Surrey basically everything
from here up and in doing so water we
actually missing in terms of making
sense of reality and how are we actually
encoding these into our machines and so
having a philosopher or someone our
psychologists as part of this design
process I think is absolutely
fundamental I agreed and mainly to say
hey what are the biases what are our
cultural biases we are and we have I
have my own and speaking this stuff
right we have plenty of them that's a
good way to view it is that when the
engineers and designers are you talked
about this the the loop where it's
almost as though it's a it's a
progression that's linear instead of
circular where it's like I just use
abuse and dispose of things well then
the philosophers there next to them and
they say like hey where do you think the
tech device is going after you finish
using it huh and then they're like I
don't know where does it go well how do
you think we can optimize the process of
passing this down to other people on the
planet to use or how do we make it so
that the that there's a zero waste or a
complete circular process with these
technology so I love that component to
it I also want to address how you I you
know you're you're super on point it is
as the technologies become democratized
to have what is like three-year-olds or
five-year-old wisdom running around with
technologies that have the potential to
cause catastrophic damage that's a
that's a that's a preventable thing and
we have to see it as a preventable thing
yeah yeah I think this is the piece of
existential risk that not enough people
are talking about it's that things like
nooks and negative ai- synthetic biology
as existential risk factors are
contingent upon us monkeys behaving and
acting in certain ways right for me that
the source of everything is the human
mind
are we in fear or are we in love are we
in
yeah a trauma response or are we healed
and that is gonna that that itself is
going to feed yes and inform what is
gonna happen with all these risks in the
future I love that so then guiding more
people towards love and towards healing
and towards especially maybe in the West
maybe towards more towards the heart and
towards in the body and what spiritual
awakening but but from a way that isn't
hippie-dippie yes so the one thing that
have really the might trigger to use a
San Francisco term about San Francisco
is it's it's this there's a lot of this
is spiritual ascension it's not granted
in the practicalities of the day and so
when I speak of love like let's think of
love like really rationally yes let's do
it alright let's go and not that love is
necessarily rational but like in order
to communicate this you know in the
language of the day of secular science
okay love is love is the cosmological
process of allurement when an out when
hydrogen and oxygen meet that is nothing
but love it's the coming together it's
the knowledge that if we want to evolve
effectively synergy and symbiosis that
can allow us to do that so differently
if we don't love any in the presence of
exponential tech all it takes and it's
decentralized all it takes is one bad
actor for the whole thing to go kaput so
love grounded love
and and the other things are in trauma
yeah I like killing people of trauma I
think a lot of people who said guards in
life are a function of them being having
been hurt and so saying the world is in
a safe place and I think people may be
thinking I'm making these numbers up but
maybe think that 60% of the world is
goods 35% of the world is sorry and 40%
the world is bad
whereas what I think is that 70% in the
world is good 25% of the world are
highly traumatized and therefore act in
bad ways and five-person in the world
are sociopathic narcissist a parasite
and that's a different matter altogether
but most bad actors are behaving from
trauma mm-hmm is my sense mm to insert
to heal that is to heal a vast majority
of the oops moments that could
potentially happen and the other in this
case in your example of other 5% are
something that needs to be handled and
no potentially I disagree I don't know
and I mean we could go down that path
there's lots of ways how what are the
the optimal ways to heal for both trauma
as well as for even the ones that are
you know benevolent actors in the world
it still creeps up yeah yeah for self
dealing behaviors these types of things
so this is just a deeper connection to
our own spiritual unity with God is that
is that is that can that solve the way
that we behave and we do we also need
updates in the social fabric away from
the tendencies towards self dealing and
stuff individual transformation is
necessary but insufficient this
individual systemic and narrative all
simultaneous completely the individual
and this is very like personal
responsibility comes in it's the thing
that we have control over
we have agency over our own lives we're
not victims just to the system the
system is playing a part but we also
have agency I think so for example some
of the psychedelic studies coming out of
Johns Hopkins is that the depth of
mysticism encountered in a psilocybin
experience
as a strong has a strong correlation
with how much feeling how much healing
that person then undergoes over the next
six months
so there's a positive correlation
between non-duality or mysticism a
single experience and healing so yes and
there are other ways to heal you know
there's basically the the pathology of
the Western medicine system is that
we're seeing all these things as
depression and anxiety as problems
they're there they're often not Thea
these are deep intelligent signals for
the body to say look look at me
and we don't partly systemically because
we can't afford to so feeling feeling is
healing and it's the biggest nerf stuff
right where all our vagus nerves are all
like in superfight flight responses
healing the vagus nerve mm-hmm many many
Whitley ways of doing this I think again
the the the biases of Western the
Western mind is that to make it all a
bit talk therapy tell me like why tell
me about your daddy issues and stuff
again necessary insufficient body
we're embodies a lot of trauma is stored
because we are somatic beings and the
trauma is it's it's very primal very
mammalian I think things that we look
there first and again this is some of
the biases that Tech move away from it's
the transhumanist reoccur as well
they're in Lourdes and it's like the
consciousness doesn't just the brain the
gut the heart mmm there's all this
intelligence
yeah well then is so then we doing so
first of all then it's not even
localized to the central nervous system
so then it's also localized to the heart
and to the gut so then yeah so that
matters that complication first of all
huh
or maybe not even localized to the body
to the body in the first place yeah and
then that goes into different
philosophical realms damn so then you
have to yeah so then you need to figure
out how to upload the trillions of cells
of the body Plus how that makes a
collective intelligence right and good
good luck I guess I just think it's
naive to just think we're gonna
understand the brain and it's gonna be
able to just the brain is gonna be
dressed like that that said I'm not a
reductive materialist and I think
probably we can upload to some degree
sure but to think this is just gonna be
as simple as the brain is I think the
the blind spot of scientific materialism
and then let's say and I guess before we
venture a little bit deeper into into
that I just want to ask you about this
where do you think that certain
philosophies and wisdoms from where you
gave this example of a lot of West's
head head up cerebral and then we have a
bunch of like ancient wisdom and
philosophies from the other parts of the
planet that's like pretty much just not
the United States where people have had
a deeper non-dual
experiences yes so yeah so how does that
how does that marriage optimally happen
and also just to be clear there are
places in the world like the tech the
massive technology giants in China that
are also doing very in this sense social
technology building yeah I mean so part
of Western biases is my myopia which
embeds itself in all our institutions so
how can we actually plan for climate
change if the lexical terms are four and
five years right China doesn't have the
same problem or the seventh-generation
principle of in
seventh-generation principle not the
same problem it's gorgeous
there's a short termism that is
catastrophic when we're trying to solve
existential long-term risks I think a I
could play a part of a big part of this
centralizing knowledge systems if AI
opposed to incorporate not just the
abstract and this is the again the other
thing have you seen those done those
studies I don't even know if they're
studies but when you ask a Japanese
person to look at a painting and they
described the environment and then then
and then they describe the animal in the
paintings second whereas the the western
wall mind goes straight to the animal
and completely forgets about the
environment Wow the we have to
understand that the way we actually
perceive phenomenologically is
contingent upon our stories and our
cultural biases so how do we bridge
these things again bringing this
knowledge bringing having you're having
an elders boards at Facebook hmm I like
that like the elders board having the
others board rather like having you know
can you imagine but that cuts into
bottom-line profits so I'm sorry yeah
yeah yeah we don't hear this yeah see
that's that's that's where that's a
really good example there's something
you know there's and shamanism bringing
and bringing these plants to the west
it's already happening
whoa something like that I don't know
what the elders boards at Google
Facebook Amazon Apple at ten cents I
knew our caucus yeah yeah and yeah let's
do it
I love ya I love it the elders boards
that's another one of those principles
if you can get 10% of venture capital
money to go to the department of nature
maintenance and every single one of the
massive corporations on the planet to
have an elders board that thinks seven
generations out and then they slowly you
know that's good also just getting
people that are in the leadership
positions to think seven generations out
themselves and become spiritually
naturally actualize them so again though
this goes if you have a if you have
political systems that are four or five
year terms like I said and you have a go
at consciousness participating in those
systems which by the way you're most
likely going to get because it's going
to self it's gonna filter out by
necessity those who are less able to
play when Lewis dominance hierarchy
games right so we have to so you have
your great consciousness short-termism
it's very very hard to so for this again
it's the individual is the systemic and
it's the narrative transformation yeah
yeah
now and to plug in the so so so we we
take our own our own reins of our own
life trajectory and experience and move
it more in the direction of spiritual
understanding and awakening and then we
also simultaneously realize that I have
to start working with friends family
people around me to help them with that
process individually and also to help
build that collective fabric and
narrative for the children as well that
we're going in that direction yeah so
then that's kind of like this process of
okay so get transforming as soon as
possible it's like that yeah yeah and
transforming doesn't necessarily like
mint button no like maybe the best tool
for you would be a three-year be a
three-year process
yeah can our tech in our science
actually understand best what our
neurology biology psychology needs in
order to optimize our spiritual growth
pattern for a long way off but that's
how I see this it's not just our oh yeah
I'm walk and again like if Ken Wilber
like States versus stages States versus
stages using the hands lot did it you
like that yeah just if you're giving
people non jewel states means nothing
for what you're actually doing to their
stage of consciousness seventy percent
in the world are an ego and ethnocentric
stages of consciousness damn it's about
me and my tribe me my religion if you're
non Jew and egocentric that's when you
get your self a a rape a guru it becomes
a rapist let me say it is both its stage
how do you increase your capacity for
empathy with others yes better handle
complexity worldcentric perspectives
yeah waking up in enough
if it took us you know sometimes it
takes us years and if not even a decade
or more to be able to get some of the
fundamental things that help us engage
in the world like a language mm-hmm
and for some reason the spiritual
awakening button is what like with this
is not an instant gratification process
neither is achieving your North Star
purpose in this world if you're along
the ride of life for the trophy in the
end you're gonna miss the whole point of
it yeah which is to love every single
moment leading towards the North Star
mission and that same process as part of
spiritual enlightenment too is that we
are in love with that moments moment
there's not an instant gratification
achieve my trophy button this is a very
long-term play but can we also help
provide the tools to win there is the
wisdom race yes I love that wisdom race
yeah that's exactly what this is yeah
yeah take mark was instrumental in
delivering that with his future of life
Institute yeah
I'm glad that also consciousness hacking
is really passionate about ancient
wisdom I think that's it's so so
critical yeah it can
the elders board there were so many good
examples of this conversation
um let's um let's visit the we're
talking about consciousnesses potential
localization or non localization the
complexity of it do we come from
somewhere else into these earth suits I
love how you ask that as if I can give a
definitive answer let me just tune in
my experience through contemplative
practice is that there is a field of
awareness that is more fundamental to us
than our narrative self the
consciousness is primary not an emergent
phenomenon not an epiphenomenon
phenomenon but is actually a
substructure of reality itself now that
could be idealism everything is mind and
we are in consciousness
it could be pen psychism consciousness
is a component of matter that's a cool
view and it basically means you can
create consciously yeah because all you
need to do is reconfigure the
constituent parts in such a way that and
an even idealism you could Crick AI that
acts as a signal you know if we're just
we're just reflecting and inflecting
consciousness as primary substrate so my
experiences we are and yeah
my experience is that we are
fundamentally awareness and I never
believe that because it's been saying
that no the non-jew LED like the Vedanta
books that I'm sure you've read and I've
read and that's Otis an idea until you
have that experience and can template
apprentice can take you to that
experience but I don't know I mean if
anybody if you have anyone in the show
that says they know some people
especially the and said the ancestral
wisdoms yeah are pretty clear about
what's been passed down to them right we
all break apart from God to come through
these these bodies and to have an
experience of remembering that we come
from God and that of achieving our
purpose remembering yeah you've been to
Burning Man not yet Neutron and I we're
trying to go soon you guys gotta go
it's a remembering like I think this is
consciousness inform having an adventure
and that's also why these like climate
crisis catastrophes it essential risk
like to some degree and I don't want to
be too easy Terra cure metaphysical here
like consciousness wants to experience
the adventure yeah we consciousness one
since one hero's journey yeah and the
more crisis the more potential for
growth the more potential for adventure
that's why potentially there are the
difficulties if they basically the idea
is that if you were born into a reality
where you instantly remembered that you
came from God and that you instantly
knew your life purpose and that you
instantly got the life purpose and there
was no evil to deal with would be like
the most boring thing evilly yes so the
fact that it's hard to remember that you
come from God it's hard to know what
your North Star is it's hard to go on
the path of the North Star it's hard
because there's a bunch of evil [ __ ] and
hard [ __ ] that comes in your way
challenges that you have to overcome
right that's what makes this whole
process fun of life think about this how
good do you feel that for a good workout
at the gym yeah like Ben you've really
Fisher so fun good that's just a
metaphor mmm like the the soul doesn't
like comfort
the other problem with tech is
convenience
we're so flippin comfortable the soul
doesn't like that there's a
that growth has to be met with
resistance mm-hmm
not easy growth yeah this is I like the
gyms of metaphor yeah yeah exercise is a
metaphor yeah for life
yeah yeah and evil yeah okay so what are
your thoughts about that what what what
are these is this a big playground
battle between the light and darkness
this feels like a loaded question this
duality of good needles are relatively
like judeo-christian cosmology and
Buddhism it's not so much it's you see
clearly or you're ignorant and ignorance
is the evil as this kind of goes back to
my trauma point I think there are evil
people in the world I think I mean I
think sociopaths make up about 3% of the
population and I think the rest of
people are actually quite um traumatized
and maybe being used as a vessel 3 oh I
don't know
again contemplative practice it laughs
that's the suggestion that the light is
necessarily better
and I mean if you go into things like
archetypes there could be some sort of
cosmic play I don't know I I don't know
I I I think it's naive to think that we
can transcend evil mmm impairment
indefinitely indefinitely and he was
part of Leela then play and it makes it
fun yes without sending to too basic
about yet right
because evils not fun for a lot of
people correct but being also being too
in a duration of it can cause the
civilization to collapse because we were
to not trying to get the wisdom meter up
fast enough so right they can have
non-jew passivity well so once it
doesn't matter and then there's a
genocide going on over there and I'm
still in the non-dual state over here
it's fine for me is the better word is
suffering a lot of evil people are
acting from places of suffering when you
clear the suffering I think you clear a
lot of the evil yeah and yeah and we
have to have the systems in place that
mean that if you are going to be evil
like you're massively disincentivized to
do so it's extremely hard if not even
impossible potentially to do so with the
technologies that could wipe out the
whole sieve yeah yeah yeah make it in
potentially impossible maybe that is the
yeah best way to do it
maybe um okay let's venture into two of
the last questions are we in a
simulation
yeah simulation is is for me it's the
same as the god question mmm it's an
inhibition of the infinite regression
yeah it's like a base ontology right so
we can stop here so we don't explain
anything else it doesn't it doesn't
matter for me it doesn't matter if it's
God if it's simulation and even if
there's a simulation then you still have
the thing where the simulation come from
etc I don't know I think this sim I
think well how we're gonna see the
simulation is because if you look at the
math and probability function it makes a
lot of sense mm-hmm right what are the
probabilities I mean if there's gonna be
infinite worlds this huge and I think my
sense is part of what we're gonna see as
part of that is the limitations of a
mathematical mindset of a mathematical
mind so the probability isn't the only
thing that's going on here
but I can't give you a deeper answer
something else
ethereal going on as well as Matt I mean
it's like just I mean even if it is mine
I mean hope is are like I'm a monkey
you're among me making mouth noises on
this planet flowing in space and with
your gravity in this infinite cosmos
like seriously what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah yeah like what the heck is going on
here man I think this is the thing to
wake people up I think people can wake
up through all not all from necessarily
from you know a peak transcendent
experiences but actually all from like
the very nature of reality it's so
exactly
if people could wake up to the fact that
this is [ __ ] bizarre yeah it's a well
yeah can you take that stream of
consciousness and can you make that
embedded into every child's experience
and make sure every parent assists with
their child to facilitate that and not
get it out of there right well not
necessarily embed it in the chose
experience but stop it from being lost
rather being from being lost yeah and so
for example sure it gets him yeah yeah
so virtual reality can give the cat ions
you know ions institute of noetic
sciences they're working on the overview
effect in VR yeah that's a huge one yeah
so giving people the yeah we're when did
we lose sight of how magnificent it is
to just be alive in the first place and
be able to have a a hmm let alone a
conversation that's being streamed to
the Internet but just even just be yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's I think what the
ancient wisdoms like hello have you
forgotten that you are alive in that
itself is a miracle yeah yeah and you
can tell and you can reflect on it and
you're aware of it yeah yeah
yeah okay and then how about what is the
most beautiful thing in the world
I think that but the very fact that we
do we exist is the most tragic joyful
existential and beautiful thing that we
could even fathom and like there is a
despair in beauty too right
you don't look at a sunset with pure joy
there's a kind of understanding of the
impairments yes and that that moves the
heart it moves the poets and the artists
beauty is is a multi-dimensional yeah
yeah just we just watched one yesterday
and yeah just gets spot-on
it's a gorgeous and then also like it's
set yeah this is an impermanent life as
well and that get to the North Star
identify the North Star and achieve the
North Star and win the wisdom race along
the way when the wisdom race yeah yeah
this has been such a good conversation
this was fun Thank You Joshua I've had a
blast thank you my remaining yeah let's
just get some something that was denied
here yeah yeah yeah
thank you for coming on thank you for
sharing all this yeah and let's get more
let's get more of the hacks of
consciousness happening around the world
so that we can win the wisdom race let's
do it across all the different ways to
do it thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode let us know what you're
thinking have more conversations and
your friends your families people online
your co-workers about ways of hacking
our consciousness psychedelics
meditation technology neuro tech biotech
ancient wisdom go and apply these things
into the world win the wisdom race
together check out Coe hack dot life
also neo gnosis calm the Facebook
YouTube pages check those out
shout out to Ron Vargas for producing
and directing thank you very much Ronnie
and support the artists the
entrepreneurs the organizations the
scientists around the world that you
believe in the indigenous tribes support
them help them pass along their wisdom
into the world support simulation our
links are below to our PayPal our
patreon or cryptocurrency help support
us and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into well they love
you very much thanks for tuning in we'll
see you soon
peace
[Music]